do you have an intuitive explanation for
people who let's say they're at the
second year level what is a homology
what's homology
it's a tough a very tough uh
question
uh because
it's many things or it's it's related to
many things
and i could answer it in in many levels
um
you know
let me
let me give you a summary answer
sure okay
so
often in mathematics
there are two ways to describe objects
you can describe them implicitly
by telling what equations they satisfy
or
explicitly
by constructing all of them
let me give you the simplest example
so
consider
the unit circle
sorry i kind of care about the points of
the unit circle so here is the unit
circle in the x y plane and here is a
point x y
the implicit description of the circle
so the implicit
is
by writing an equation which the points
have to satisfy and everybody knows what
the equation is the equation is x
squared minus sorry plus y squared minus
one is equal to zero
okay
uh
but there is also an explicit
description
and again i'm not sure which one is
why the naming is such but it it doesn't
really matter namely i can construct all
the points of the paper of the circle
and the construction is you set x is
equal to
cosine of theta and y is equal to sine
of theta
okay
now this is the general
a general feature in mathematics that
many things can be described either be
constructed that's the explicit
or be defined by an equation
now
if you
uh
restrict your attention to linear
algebra
if you you you you do the same thing but
in linear algebra
then
uh
the situation is that you have some
space in the middle maybe it's a vector
space
and inside inside that space you want to
describe things
actually i'm not sure why i'm drawing it
curve because the curve because if it's
linear algebra should be drawing it
straight but anyway you want to describe
things
and there are two ways to describe them
one way
is by saying
these things
well you construct a map into another
space
and you say
these things
are the things in the kernel
of this map so i don't know what let's
call this map
fi
and these things
are the kernel of phi
and then
um
uh
uh the so this is the implicit
description
this is you describe the things by an
equation and and then there is also the
explicit description so you have yet
another vector space
and you have a map let's call it let's
call it psi
and you say
the things here
that are
well the good things like the points of
the circle
are the image of psy
so you say these are the things that are
the image of psy
okay and this corresponds to the
explicit
view you construct the things you
present them as an image via some
operation
uh
coming from some you know maybe
some smaller dimensional space
okay
uh so
okay
here's a funny thing so
if your construction is
reasonable then everything you construct
solves the equations
in other words everything in the image
of psi
is contained in the kernel of phi so
once you have a situation like this you
know that you're going to have that the
image of psy
is contained in the kernel
of
phi and in fact if you're constructing
the exact same things
then the image of i will be equal
to the kernel of i not just contained
okay and then you will be saying that
the situation is exact
things got
exactly the things that you've
constructed are the things that you
described by the equations
but that's not always the case
sometimes you have equations defining
something and you want to know did i
construct all the solutions
so sometimes this inclusion
is strict
and then you want to measure
by how much
or how much did you fail
so how much did you not construct
everything and that's exactly the
difference between the kernel of i and
the image of psy and in linear algebra
the difference is quotient so you take
the quotient space
and this is the so-called homology
so somehow homology measures
uh so this measures
uh
uh
how
good
are
your
uh constructions
did you construct everything or did you
leave some stuff out
is the kernel the implicit the
description
does it contain more things than than
you've constructed
so somehow homology measures how good
are your constructions and this is true
in general
uh
and and and then there are lots and lots
and lots and lots of specific examples
uh
and
um
to some extent it's a bit of magic i'm
not sure i i can give you a really good
explanation
why there are so many examples and why
so much of mathematics
end up
having close relationships with with
with uh with homology maybe this is a
partial explanation so
basically you always want to measure how
good is what you've done
so
are you able to talk about what co
homology is and then homology's
relationship to cohomology or is that a
whole other can of worms it's another
kind of forms but
in some sense it's not interesting
in in some philosophical sense it's not
interesting
so when i described kohomolo also
it's essentially the same
so
the difference between a homology and
co-homology more than anything else is a
difference of conventions whether your
map goes from left to right or from
right to left
it's it's uh
from this
perspective from this very far away and
very imprecise perspectives there's
really no difference